♪ [slow somber piano music]
[sound of typing]
[sound of 2.0 falling down]
Hank: Good morning, John.
It is Wednesday, December 19th
and because it is a Wednesday
you know and everybody should know
that of course I have to sing a song.
And this is the final song
Wednesday of Brotherhood 2.0!
Because it is my last Wednesday,
holy crap!
But is it also a historic song Wednesday
because it is the first song Wednesday
in which I am not going to be alone
in my singing,
because Katherine is going to help me.
She wrote probably about
a half of this song, actually.
Katherine: Um-hum.
Hank: She was very excited
about the whole secret project.
She was in there commenting
with everyone else.
We had a "Mission Control" in our basement
and we had a lot of fun.
This song is about the secret project
for awesome.
♪ [guitar playing]
[Hank and Katherine sing]
♪ December 17th was the day.
♪ The Project for
Awesome got Underway
♪ With a goal to decrease WorldSuck
with the help of sXePhil,
♪ Nalts and Whatthebuck
♪ It was the day that the Nerds
took over YouTube
♪ They got together to prove
♪ That believe it or not
♪ Their center screenshot was actually
more powerful than two boobs
♪ [guitar playing]
♪ People promoted 300 charities like levees.org,
toys for tots and autism speaks
♪ Nerdfighters of every race, creed and age
♪ They commented that shit
to the most discussed page
♪ It was the day that the nerds took over YouTube
♪ They got together to prove
that believe it or not
♪ their center screenshot was actually
more powerful than two boobs
Hank: ♪ It was the day that the nerds
took over YouTube!
[both laughing]
[sound of hands slapping each other]
Hank: So that was our song.
The secret project was really exciting.
And not only was it sort of fantastically jokes-
I guess it made me kind of hopeful
seeing all of these people that I know
and people that I don't know
promoting these organizations
that are doing really good things.
And they're so many of them, so many people
doing awesome stuff in the world
just because they think that
it's the right thing to do.
Thanks for everyone who participated.
Thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you.
Should I do that more?
Should I say thank you more?
And thanks to everyone who skipped school
or didn't go into work.
I didn't go into work that day either.
I'm not looking forward to
your punishment proposals.
Katherine: Me either.
Hanks: [laughs]
Katherine: Because I'm the one
that has to video you, it.
Hank: That's, that's true-
Katherine: And in many cases--
Hank: You definitely does have to
deal with the camera.
The person who said that I had to pay five
dollars for every hand gesture in every video,
that was a really bad idea.
I'd probably would--
would, would be destitute.
There's no other way for me
to show how excited I am! [laughs]
Wheeee.
So John I'm not looking forward
to your punishment proposals,
but I will see them and you tomorrow.
Hank: Is there anything
you wanna say to John?
Katherine: Where's out Christmas present? [laughing]
Hank: John just called us like
five minutes ago and he was like,
"What kind of manga do you like?
Katherine: [laughing]
Hank: [laughs] He had to ask us.
Kathreine: [laughing] I love you buck.
Hank: I'm gonna turn it off.
I don't know how much of this
I'm gonna be able to use.
both: Uh.